>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Kevin Amer: Good
morning, everyone.
I think we're about
ready to get started.
Welcome to the second
day of our roundtables
for the Copyright Office's
study on section 1201.
Before we begin, I just would like
to go over a few logistical items.
Apologies to those of you
who heard this yesterday.
But first of all, my
name is Kevin Amer.
I'm a Senior Counsel
in the Office of Policy
and International Affairs
here at the Copyright Office.
The roundtable sessions will be
moderated by us here at the table.
We will pose questions to begin the
discussion on particular topics.
As most of you know, we ask
that to indicate that you'd
like to be called on, if you
could please turn your name
placard vertically.
Just given the number of
panelists and topics, we ask that,
if possible, you could try
to confine your comments
to about two to three minutes.
We apologize in advance if we
have to cut you off, but you know,
we appreciate your
understanding on that.
We also ask that you please
obviously focus your comments
on the specific topics that were
raised in the notice of inquiry
and that are asked in our questions.
And finally, just at
the end of your comment,
if you could please turn
off your microphone,
because that avoids interference
with the sound recording.
Our final session of the day is
an audience participation session.
And time permitting, additional
comments from the participants.
For the audience, there
will be a sign-up sheet.
And again, we ask that comments made
in that session be
limited to two minutes.
In addition, as you can see, today's
event is being video recorded
by the Library of Congress.
Participants, we provided you
with a video release form.
If you haven't yet signed it,
please do so and return it
to any one of us here at the table.
For audience members
participating in the last session,
if you do decide to participate,
you will be giving us permission
to include your questions or
comments in any future webcasts
and broadcasts of this event.
In addition, as you can see,
we do have a court reporter
transcribing the proceedings.
Finally, we just would like to note
that we may seek additional written
comments in response to issues
that may come up during
the roundtables.
If we do so, we will issue a
formal Federal Register notice
as previously.
At this time, I would just like
to ask everyone in the audience
to please turn off
or mute any devices
that might interfere
with the recording.
Does anyone have any questions about
logistics before we get started?
OK, great.
Before we begin, I'd just
like to invite my office
colleagues to introduce themselves.
>> Andrew Moore: Andrew Moore,
I'm a Ringer Fellow at
the Copyright Office.
>> Jason Sloan: Jason Sloan,
I'm an Attorney-Advisor
in the General Counsel's Office.
>> Regan Smith: Regan Smith,
Associate General Counsel.
>> Kevin Amer: And
so, before we begin,
I'd like to invite the panelists
to just go around quickly
and state your name and affiliation.
>> Allan Adler: Allan Adler.
I'm with the Association
of American Publishers.
>> June Besek: June Besek.
I'm the Executive Director of
the Kernochan Center for Law,
Media and the Arts at
Columbia Law School.
>> Brandon Butler: Brandon Butler.
I'm the Director of
Information Policy
at the University of
Virginia Library.
>> Seth Greenstein: Seth Greenstein,
from the Law Firm of
Constantine Cannon.
I'm here today as the aftermarket
replacement part for Aaron Lowe,
of the Auto Care Association.
>> Keith Kupferschmid:
Keith Kupferschmid,
CEO of the Copyright Alliance.
>> James Love: Jamie Love,
Knowledge Ecology International.
>> David M. Perry: David Perry,
from the law firm Blank Rome
in Philadelphia, on
behalf of Dorman Products,
which is an aftermarket
auto parts company.
>> Ben Sheffner: Ben
Sheffner, Vice President,
Legal Affairs at the Motion
Picture Association of America.
>> Robert S. Schwartz: Robert
Schwartz, Constantine Cannon.
I'm counsel to Consumer
Technology Association.
>> Bruce Turnbull: Bruce Turnbull,
counsel to the DVD Copy
Control Association,
and the Advanced Access Content
System Licensing Administrator LLC.
>> Kevin Amer: Great.
Thank you.
So this panel, as you know, involves
the anti-trafficking provisions
of section 1201.
And to kick things off, I'm
going to turn it over to Regan
with a few introductory remarks.
>> Regan Smith: Yeah.
So the anti-trafficking provisions
of section 1201 are not part
of the triennial rulemaking,
as I think you know.
But they are generally provisions
upon both access controls
and section 1201(b), which
applies to copy controls.
In many of the comments we
received, we heard arguments
that the intended beneficiaries
of exemptions to the provision
on circumvention are difficult for
the intended beneficiaries to engage
in without assistance
from third parties.
And the most recent rulemaking, the
Register of copy Rights recommended
to the Librarian some of the
difficulties that have arisen
with anti-trafficking provision.
She stated, "Congress may wish
to consider clarifications
to section 1201 to ensure that the
beneficiaries of exemptions are able
to take full advantage of them,
even if they need assistance
from third parties.
While the anti-trafficking
provisions can curtail bad actors
seeking to profit from
circumvention by others,
they also constrain the ability
that allows third parties
to offer assistance
to exempted users."
So as the first question to kickoff
I think rather broadly is how
effective are the participants
feeling that the provisions are--
the anti-trafficking
provisions have been
at encouraging the innovative
digital distribution to models
and deterring infringements.
Mr. Turnbull.
>> Bruce Turnbull: In both the DVD
and Blu-ray case and now hopefully
in the Ultra-HD Blu-ray
case, the availability
of the content protection systems,
the technological protection
measure, CSS and AACS
and now AACS-2 were essential to
the development of those markets.
And the anti-trafficking provisions
have been essential to the integrity
of the licensing of
those technologies.
Both DVD CCA and AACS
have taken advantage
of the anti-trafficking provisions
in court cases against entities
that are distributing, trafficking
in circumvention products.
They are absolutely essential to
the business of both of my clients
and to the development of the market
where consumers have
enjoyed tremendous new ways
of enjoying the content
in the digital era.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Adler?
>> Allan Adler: For the publishing
industry that the importance
of the anti-trafficking
provision can be overstated.
The fact of the matter is again,
we're dealing with a situation
where we're talking
about circumvention
of technological protection measures
that don't involve all the
complications of dealing
with software that has a separate
functionality besides the fact
that it is serving as a gate
essentially for authentication
of who has access to works.
So if you think about
the way the explosion
in online subscription
services for journals, e-books,
variety of other content have
taken place, it's all taken place
because of the ability to have that
kind of arrangement where authorized
and authenticated access is
done by passwords generally.
And those passwords can't be
circumvented, at least to the extent
that there's not wide availability
of the kinds of tools or devices
or services that would proliferate
and basically threaten
that type of model.
>> Regan Smith: Can you
elaborate for a second on the role
of the law there in
encouraging these models
and protecting the password
as opposed to just the fact
that there is a password on it?
Are there-- Do you have to take and
undertake enforcement activities
or do you think it is just
a broader deterrent effect?
>> Allan Adler: Again,
as I said yesterday,
I don't think the law
had the expectation
where Congress enacted it, that
it was going to really be able
to prevent or even
deter hackers as such.
What it was designed to do, as
most laws are, is to make sure
that law-abiding people
remain law-abiding.
And so, the notion that you
could have some kind of locks
that you're permitted to use,
you're not required to use them
but you're permitted to use them
without having legal protections
against people constantly
trying and succeeding ultimately
in circumventing those
locks would mean
that locks themselves would
be ultimately ineffectual.
So the law is very important as a
general matter not because it deters
or prevents the hackers who
are determined to engage
in illegal activity but it
generally means that people
who are law-abiding citizens
will respect the business model
and will participate use
of that business model
understanding why they need
to have their authorizations
authenticated.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
I think Mr. Kupferschmid is next.
>> Keith Kupferschmid: Yeah.
Thank you.
It's pretty clear I think that
consumers in the United States,
as well as, you know, large
and small copyright owners,
have benefited from this sort
of explosion of innovation
and this explosion of
innovation that we see is due,
at least in part, because of the
protection provided in section 1201
and the anti-trafficking provisions.
Those anti-trafficking
provisions have been a very,
very important part of 1201
since the very beginning.
It's our belief that they shouldn't
be cut back on at this point.
I mean, as Allan mentioned,
you know, the purpose,
the ultimate purpose is to keep
sort of this hacking software
out of the mainstream and limit
its availability to the fringes,
you know, so you can't
just walk into Best Buy,
for instance, and get a copy.
But there are other--
many other benefits.
It prevents tracking in
circumvention technologies.
By doing that, it reduces
the attractiveness
of commercial business
models that are based
on enabling access
to infringing works.
Being able to target trafficking
is also important because actions
of distributors that
circumvent that--
Sorry, distributors
of the circumvention
technologies is comparatively--
I repeat, comparatively
easy to detect
and targeting them is the most
efficient and effective way
to actually enforce 1201.
And then, it also helps prevent
the sort of capital formation
around the black box business
dedicated to circumvention of sales
of circumvention devices and prevent
sort of this arms race, if you will,
where, you know, a
technology is cracked
and the black boxes are out there.
And so, you have to
create a new technology.
And it just-- And I think
that's the benefit of everyone.
And just lastly, just to
repeat is what Allan said,
it ultimately keeps
consumers honest, if you will,
preventing circumvention tools
from being conveniently available
at Best Buy, Amazon,
Newegg and things like that.
That's the underlying
purpose and I think--
And I think a lot of people
agree with me that it has served
that purpose and served
that purpose well and is
in large part responsible for
the tremendous boom in innovation
that we have today and
these new business models
that consumers have
access to movies and music
and all sorts of copyrighted works.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Love, would you agree
with that characterization?
Do you have a different take?
If you can turn your
microphone on and speak into it?
>> James Love: No.
>> Regan Smith: Oh, OK.
Well, you had your placard up.
So I didn't know if you had
another thought you wanted to share.
>> James Love: Yeah.
I do, yes.
I mean, there's a wide range of
areas where the public interest
in having companies
protect their works
through technical measures
are appropriate.
But I think as the evidence
in this proceeding has shown,
and in other proceedings has
shown, there's a whole set of areas
where it doesn't work out well.
It has perhaps like an
anti-competitive effect
or it defeats people from being able
to use lawful exceptions
and things like that.
So I think that the task for this
group going forward is to figure
out how do you address the fact
that the law covers a lot of stuff
and not everything is
exactly the same in terms
of the way things play out.
To us, part of it's what
obligations do you put on people.
Part of the answer is what
obligations do you put on people
that provide-- that
expect legal protections
from the technical measures.
In other words, is there-- can
you just do anything and expect
to be protected with a full weight
of, you know, all the laws coming
down on your head if you violate
anything, no matter what the context
or the circumstances is, or do you
have any obligation to address some
of the other issues
that may come up,
that many which are
raised in the proceeding.
So part of it's that, and part of
it is do you have the same rules
for every sector of the economy.
Is it the same thing for movies as
it is for auto parts, for example,
which will be discussed here?
Is it the same thing
for textbooks as it is
for computer games and things?
And I think it's a mistake
to have a unitary system
where everything is
kind of thrown together.
So I think part of the way forward
is to recognize that not all uses
of goods present the same problems.
Part of the solution is to--
is to realize that there should
be some affirmative obligations
on people that expect legal
protection in the state to,
you know, help enforce their
technical protection measures
to address public interest in areas.
And I think the other area is it
may be that there's more of a realm
for a category of people
that are authorized
to use circumvention devices
under certain contexts.
For example, in the
area for blind people,
it's great that blind
people have the,
you know, the right to circumvent.
But I mean, it's not something
that all blind people can do
without depending on someone
to provide a service for them.
Same thing I'm sure is for
people that want to, you know,
fix their own cars or
something like that.
Not everybody can do
these things on their own.
But it may be that you-- in some
areas, you may feel like you want
to have some-- not completely
open the door all the way,
but you may want to have some
some sense that the people
that are authorized
to provide services
like that are somehow
more accountable
and following some more
circumspect things.
And so I think just in
terms of opening things,
that's what I wanted to say.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Thank you.
So that-- That raised a lot of
issues, some of which we'll unpack
as we go throughout the discussion.
But one follow-up question for you,
before I let Ms. Besek speak is,
you know, yesterday
on our first panel,
as well as the Copyright Office's
study on embedded software devices,
which was the panel two--
the roundtables two days ago,
we talked about whether there was
a way to sort of divide the line
between software and embedded
devices, perhaps not related
to the distribution
of expressive content
such as a garage door opener,
a car versus the consumption
of books, movies, music.
Is that-- It sounds like you think
some line on that may be relevant
to the anti-trafficking laws?
Would that-- Would you support--
Are you suggesting statutory reform?
>> James Love: Well,
I think statutory reform
should always be considered.
And we would support
statutory reform.
But whether you do it within
the discretion you have,
it's a rulemaking, or whether you
do it through statutory reform,
I think these distinctions
should be followed.
I also think you can make
distinctions between content
such as entertainment products,
such as movies or computer games
from material that's used
in an educational context.
It just is another illustration
of an additional distinction
you can make.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Ms. Besek?
Excuse me?
>> June Besek: It didn't
go all the way.
So I guess I'm not as
certain as Mr. Love is
about how you can make these
discriminations between content,
because I think that educators and
librarians would say that movies
and other kinds of works
are very relevant--
you know, music and
things like that.
So I think one of the difficulties
that we all face is
how to draw lines.
For example, I am sympathetic to the
notion that technological protection
that protects functional works
might be in a different category.
However, how do you distinguish
between computer software
that runs a particular function,
car, whatever and the fact
that there still may be a
lot of protectable expression
in that computer program.
We have to make distinctions
somehow.
The other point I wanted
to make originally was
that there were a number
of comments to the effect
that the system isn't
working anyway.
So why should people be concerned
about anti-trafficking
exceptions or other exemptions.
And I would say that it's-- a lot
of this isn't a black
or white, an either/or.
You can't argue that a
system isn't effective just
because some people can bypass.
There's always been some
degree of infringement.
There always will be.
The real goal is to
reduce it to the level
where you still have
a viable market.
So that-- I think that goes back
to Keith's comment about, you know,
you don't want it just
available at Best Buy.
Well, you don't want
it just available--
I was thinking of Walmart,
actually Keith, but the same idea.
And so, it's really important
that that material not be--
you know, the circumvention means
not be so generally available.
>> Regan Smith: So you would agree
to keep it out of Walmart, Best Buy,
sort of the easy access to
the law-abiding citizens
and the hackers can find
things in the dark corners
and that's not proof
that it's not working?
>> June Besek: Right.
>> Kevin Amer: Just to
sort of follow up on that,
and I think this picks up on
something that Mr. Love said,
we had a lot of comments drawing
the distinction between devices--
circumvention devices and services.
And there was a lot of concern
expressed about the need
for beneficiaries of exemptions
to use or just seek assistance
from third parties in
order for the exemptions
to have any practical effect.
I wonder just from your experience,
to what extent is that a concern?
Have you seen that out
in the marketplace?
And if so, to what extent should
the law recognize that sort
of distinction and what would you
suggest could be done about it?
I believe Mr. Adler was next.
If you'll-- I know you
may have had a comment
about the previous question, but
feel free to address this as well.
>> Allan Adler: Yeah.
I think that the real problem here--
it's not so much distinguishing
between levels of protection
for different types of works.
I mean, the issue of dealing
with embedded software
in consumer products and the
functionality issue with respect
to driving those products,
again, should not become the tail
that wags the anti-circumvention
dog because the issue
for anti-circumvention was primarily
about protecting access
to expressive works.
And the problem with that is, in
response to what Jamie suggested,
is simply that there's no way to
allow for the dissemination of tools
that only enable the exercise
of exemptions or other kinds
of authorized circumventions.
Let me give you an analogy when we
talk about third-party assistance.
In most jurisdictions, if you want
to go into business as a locksmith
or if you want to seek employment as
a locksmith, you have to be bonded.
You have to be certified.
You have to be licensed.
And the tools that you're able
to acquire are very carefully
regulated and tracked.
And those are mechanical tools,
very distinctive types of tools.
What we're talking about in the
online world, when we're talking
about circumventing various types of
technological protection measures,
we're primarily talking about
software acting on software
or we're talking about things
like random number generators
that are going to try to find the
proper password or the combination
for the authentication key that
allows somebody to access the works.
And it's clear that those
types of things are going
to have many legitimate uses
as well as they're going
to have these types
of illegitimate uses.
And it seems that it's going to
be extremely difficult to be able
to identify them, to be able to
regulate them, to be able to ensure
that the people who would
be authorized to use them
to perform circumventions are
in fact also properly regulated.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Greenstein?
>> Seth Greenstein: Thank you.
So there are a few issues
here I'd like to address
from the past few questions.
So I appreciated Mr. Adler trying
to draw the distinction between,
you know, access to expressive
works versus trying to get access
to the functional aspects of the
work or the aspects of a software
that control function and
have no other purpose.
And I think that really is
a line that is easy to draw.
I mean, where the software
interoperates with the part,
controls the part and is
really part of the part.
It's inseparable from the part.
I think what we're talking about,
the ability to circumvent a
technological protection measure
to get access to the
work is really all
about repairing the functionality,
augmenting the functionality,
customizing the functionality
and not anything having to do
with the expressiveness of the work.
Some of these software, in fact,
may not be copyrightable at all.
There's one case in
the Ford versus Autel,
where the court basically found
this is not copyrightable--
the elements that you're trying to
get access to are not copyrightable.
And the same was true in the Lexmark
versus Static Control
Components case,
where they found the software
was not protectable by copyright.
So that's one issue.
Looking at the real object of
protection here, the real object
of protection is not
the expressive nature
of the software, the software code.
The real object of protection
is the functionality provided
and stopping others from
repairing that functionality,
stopping competition in the
repair of consumer products.
And that being the case, I mean,
it's really an interesting question
as to whether section 1201(a)
actually applies or (a)(1)
or (a)(2) really applies because
the consumer owns the work--
I mean, owns the product
and has the right of access
to all the functionality
provided by the product.
So is there really
an issue with access?
The consumer has authorized access
to the functionality provided
by the software and that is the
only purpose of the software.
So I would say a good argument could
be made that there's no 1201(a)(1)
or (a)(2) issue to begin with and
the same would be true for (b).
Lastly, I do want to address one
of the points that you raised
with respect to the differences
between devices and services.
I think you cannot
make that distinction,
particularly for the
auto repair industry,
simply because not every mom
and pop shop-- repair shop--
is going to have the ability
to develop the software
that circumvents, that is able to
then repair the software in the car.
But everyone should be able
to use a tool that is provided
by someone else, developed
by somebody else that enables
that repair, which is why I think
you cannot really make the divide
based on devices versus services.
So I think the divide really
has to be between protection
of functionality versus
protection of expression.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
I wanted to ask a question that
sort of ties what you've said
to what Mr. Adler just said.
Mr. Adler mentioned that it would
be difficult to limit any exemption
to assistance for permitted
exemption.
And you're saying there's
sometimes trouble taking advantage
of the exemption on behalf
of the intended beneficiary.
So my question is to what extent
have the intended beneficiaries
of the Office's exemptions
relied on tools or services
that would be subject to the
anti-trafficking provision?
So I guess, you know,
getting something maybe
in a way they're not supposed to be.
And on the flipside, how much are
they prevented from being able
to make use of the exemptions?
So, Mr. Schwartz?
>> Robert S. Schwartz: Well,
you've started off by observing
that anti-trafficking really
isn't implicated in 1201(a)(1).
And I think that kind
of answers the question.
I'd like to quote somebody, and
it was in our comments, a quote:
"In our view, manufacturers,
consumers, retailers
and servicers should
not be prevented
from correcting an
interoperability problem resulting
from a protection measure causing
one or more devices in a home
or in a business to
fail to interoperate
with other technologies."
And that was Chairman Bliley of the
House Commerce Committee at the time
on August 8th, 1998 in
his floor statement.
I think he would have included autos
if one would have envisioned
the importance
of functional software at the time.
So I think the answer is simply
leave trafficking to the courts,
where it belongs, and where I
know Mr. Turnbull has been very
interested in those things.
When it comes to the question of the
Office's role and the NTIA's role
in exemptions, I think
honestly the NTIA had it right
and the Office didn't.
There should be a presumption,
at the very least,
that somebody is entitled
to service,
however the service is provided,
whether strictly as a service
or taking advantage-- or the
servicer taking advantage
of a device-- when it comes
to the exemption process.
And I would say that when the
question is interoperability
and functionality, that the
presumption should be conclusive.
I'm not here to talk about
the expressive end of that.
CTA may have a range
of views on that.
But CTA was extremely concerned
with the outcome of the proceeding
with respect to autos and also with
the reference to the Unlocking Act.
I mean, again, to refer
to what everybody knows
about the tools being
widely available to people,
when the Office processed
the previous exemption
and the Congress considered the
Unlocking Act, everybody knew
that unlocking a cell phone required
some type of expert assistance.
And it didn't seem to
trouble the Office in the past
when it granted the exemption.
The Congress acknowledged
that in legislative debate.
I don't think anybody contemplated
that the fact that Congress said,
oh yeah, you're entitled to
expert assistance in the context
of cell phones, meant you couldn't
have it when it came to autos.
I've used up much of my time.
>> Kevin Amer: Can I--
just to follow up--
Just to clarify, so when
you talk about a presumption
that third party assistance
should be allowed to make use
of an exemption, is that your
understanding of current law
or is that a change that
you would like to see?
And is there any relevance to the
fact that in the Unlocking Act,
Congress expressly provided
for third party assistance?
Does that speak to what current
law may or may not provide?
>> Robert S. Schwartz: The
answers are both and no.
The-- I think the CTA's
comments argued
by quoting this legislative
history and others
that there was no intention for an
exemption for third party assistance
to be unavailable in
the exemption context,
so long as it didn't
affect the legal environment
with respect to trafficking.
If-- CTA would be in favor of
clarifying the law in this regard,
and so advised the House
Judiciary Committee.
And as one, who on behalf of a
cell phone reseller was, you know,
involved as a stakeholder
in legislative discussions,
I don't think anybody had in
mind that this would be decided
by the Copyright Office or
the Register as a reason to--
the first time the subject
came up at all, to say, oh no,
you're not entitled to
third party assistance.
Thank you.
>> Regan Smith: Mr.
Sheffner, do you have a view
on Mr. Schwartz's interpretation?
>> Ben Sheffner: Sure.
I'll get to that in a second.
Let me just back up for a second.
First of all, I just
want to attach myself to
and endorse the previous comments
of Mr. Turnbull and Mr. Adler
and Mr. Kupferschmid
about the importance
of the anti-trafficking
provisions to the success
of the motion picture industry,
various business models
over the last 15 years, from
DVDs and Blu-rays to all
of the explosion now of 115 legal
online services here in the US,
over 400 worldwide, virtually all
of which incorporate technological
protection measures of course
with the backstop of section 1201,
both the anti-circumvention
provisions
and the anti-trafficking provisions.
But getting to your question
from a minute ago specifically
about whether the prohibitions
on trafficking
in anti-circumvention devices
and services have impeded people's
ability to exercise the exemptions
that they've been granted
through the triennial rulemaking,
and I think the answer is no.
I think if you go and look back
at the record established during
those six rulemakings now,
as well as the record developed
through these proceedings here,
you don't have people coming
forward and saying, you know what,
the Copyright Office
told me it's OK to do x,
y and z under this exemption.
However, I'm not able to do it
because of the anti-trafficking
provisions.
>> Regan Smith: Can I--
>> Ben Sheffner: At least
in the audiovisual sector,
which I was concerned about.
>> Regan Smith: Yeah, I was
going to ask you is that,
do you have an opinion
about the auto industry
or would you just treat that
as, you know, not in your--
>> Ben Sheffner: I'm
going to stay focused
for the moment on our own industry.
You know, as Mr. Adler and
Mr. Kupferschmid alluded to,
we know that there are
anti-circumvention--
There is anti-circumvention
software available out there.
It's not importantly on the shelf
at Best Buy, et cetera, et cetera.
And we think that's an
important distinction.
If it were on the shelf at Best Buy
or you could go to Amazon or Newegg
and click it, it would essentially
send a message to the public that,
hey, it's OK as a general matter
to use anti-circumvention
software, which it's not.
Again, we acknowledge that there is
nonetheless such software out there.
And again, I don't think there is
evidence established by the record
of either the triennial rulemakings
or in this proceeding that shows
that those people who have been sort
of granted exemptions
are nonetheless not able
to take advantage of those
exemptions due to the prohibition
on trafficking and circumvention
of devices and services.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Butler, you've represented
people who have, you know,
petitioned for an exemption.
Do you have a viewpoint on that?
>> Brandon Butler: Yes, absolutely.
So, I got a few things to say.
So one is a key reason that none
of the folks that I've worked
with in the past and now
have been terribly deterred
yet by anti-trafficking is
that we're free-riding
on the pirates, right?
I mean, we just-- Handbrake
is there.
It's easy to find and so if you
want to rip a DVD, it's easy to do
because luckily the things we
want to rip are also things
that pirates want to rip, right?
And so, we get to-- I
mean that it's just--
>> Regan Smith: You don't need
it to be at Best Buy to find it.
>> Brandon Butler: You don't
need it to be at Best Buy, right.
It's easily-- You just Google it.
And so-- Sorry Google.
So-- I'll be quoted on that.
I'm sorry.
But the problem I think that I
see going forward is that we are--
It's been like a-- University
of Virginia, for example,
we're really interested
and investing heavily
in digital preservation and we're
building special collections
of digital archives.
So we have Salman Rushdie's laptop
and everything that was on it.
Some of that stuff is
in proprietary formats.
I foresee that as DRM
ages, it will--
more and more different formats will
become obsolete and we'll be asking
for exemptions to crack things that
no one cares about but us, right?
And so, the pirates are
not going to make emulators
for obscure 1980s, you
know, DRM software.
And so, what are we going
to do in that context?
I think we have to be a little
bit forward-thinking about that.
And even if, right, we build
some internal expertise, and so,
some archivist is-- We have
very talented archivists
who could build that tool.
Can they share it across consortia?
That's generally the
way these things work.
So that's one worry that I have, is
we've been free-riding on pirates
because we've only asked for DVDs.
But in the future, what will we
do when we're asking for more
and more obscure formats?
And then, another thing-- Well,
did you have a follow-up
question about that?
>> Regan Smith: Yeah,
I guess-- Sorry.
If you're suggesting that, you
know, you develop an archivist
who can create this tool and then
shares it with another archivist,
that that would implicate
1201(b) and trafficking
in a technology product or service?
I mean, is that what you're
saying the-- you have a fear?
>> Brandon Butler: That's
what I would fear, right,
and there would be some
uncertainty about that.
Or that, you know, a very-- Another
way that libraries frequently work--
universities, you know,
there are of course many,
many vendors who are experts who
are external to the university
who develop specialized
products and services only
for libraries, only
for universities.
And it may be that they might
develop the better tool than we did.
And an exemption might
empower them to do that.
So that would certainly be, right--
I mean, and so maybe the archivists
working inside could make it
and maybe they could share it.
But certainly, you know, a
specialized vendor couldn't say,
hey, we've got a way to
facilitate digital preservation.
>> Regan Smith: Right.
But so if the exemption
process were to extend to sort
of encouraging this market for
circumvention tools, I mean,
would that lead into some of the
other concerns we opened up and,
you know, to encourage
your vendors to market
and sell these tools it seems
that might implicate
what others have said.
>> Brandon Butler:
Well, I think not.
I think there's security
built into the--
in fact, built into the whole
reason that we would be coming
to the table, which is
that no one else cares.
And so, Best Buy would
not want to buy, you know,
Windows 98 proprietary
file format emulators.
And so, there's just no--
The consumers don't care.
I think no one at this
table would actually care.
They wouldn't be harmed.
And so, as is often the case,
it would sort of only be the
conscientious folks who are trying
to do their jobs who would
be deterred in that context.
>> Regan Smith: Ms. Besek,
did you want to respond?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Sorry, the microphone.
>> June Besek: There
was an earlier comment
about whether the Copyright Office
has the power to do certain things
under regulations or
whether it would have
to be an amendment to the law.
And I don't think you can
really argue that things
like permitting anti-trafficking
or circumvention services are
currently embraced within the law.
I mean, there are specific places
where it's permitted in section 1201
and elsewhere-- You
know, encryption research
and I think reverse engineering
where there's-- is that--
Yeah, for interoperability.
You know, I think there
are-- and law enforcement.
But I think that in general, the
way the statute is structured,
there really is no good argument
that you can do that now.
That's not to say that the
law couldn't be amended
and we're talking here about
whether that's a good idea or not.
But I don't think it can just be
done right now through regulation.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Perry, you've had your
placard up for a while.
>> David M. Perry:
Well, not surprisingly,
I guess I would echo a lot of
what Mr. Greenstein was saying.
Even this discussion so far
today I think illustrates
that not all software is created
equal, that maybe the expressive
versus the functionality
divide is something
that really needs to be focused on.
And maybe it's easier when
you're in the automotive realm.
Maybe that's an easier case
because everybody-- Not everybody.
I think a lot of people
can appreciate that a lot
of the software that's in
your car is not expressive.
It's functional.
It's literally under the hood.
And in fact, it's all over your car.
It's hidden to everybody.
And you know, whether there will be
litigation to bear out that software
that now serves what was once a
purely electromechanical function
does not enjoy protection
at all-- that may happen.
It may happen in litigation,
which of course is very costly.
We-- You know, our client, an
aftermarket auto parts company,
a large company in that
space, was watching, you know,
with a lot of interest how the
exemption was going to come out--
if it was going to come out
and how it would be worded.
And so, you know, I think it's
worth noting that if you look
at the proposed class 21exemption
and you compare it with how it came
out in the end, you know, the
proposed class included wording,
you know, by or on behalf
of the lawful owner.
We were very interested
in that wording.
Our client does a lot of
work on behalf of owners.
Virtually no one in this
room probably could fix most
of their car by themselves anymore.
And if you look at the
final class exemption,
it now says by the authorized owner.
So our client and many others in
the aftermarket space I think looked
at that and said we still don't
have the clarity that we need
to do what we do, which is hundreds
of billions of dollars industry.
And I think everybody-- Everyone
who has a car, if they haven't gone
to your local mechanic yet and
been told that there's something
that they just simply can't
fix because of the complexity
in the software, that's
going to happen
and it's increasingly occurring.
And so, as Mr. Greenstein said,
you know, there is a competitive--
or anti-competitive aspect to
this that has to be addressed.
And you know, there needs to
be a way that the aftermarket--
whether it's automotive or
others-- can deal with software.
And I know that's sort of
embedded software which was dealt
with separately-- but you know,
the expressive and the functional,
that's a pretty important line.
>> Kevin Amer: To that
point-- Sorry.
I mean, are there any, sort
of, lessons in that respect
that we can draw from
the Unlocking Act?
I mean, has there been an
increase in sort of, you know,
services that content owners might
find objectionable as a result
of the third party
assistance being provided for?
Please
>> Robert S. Schwartz: No.
>> Kevin Amer: Anyone else want to--
Well, Mr. Love can respond to that
or to the previous question.
>> James Love: Allan
Adler brought up the issue
of regulation of locksmiths.
I think that's something that
people probably should take a harder
look at.
If-- I don't think locksmiths
are really regulated everywhere.
But I think that in some
states, they definitely are.
And I think the idea that you'd have
people that have access to tools
that are not generally
available and that
in some cases they're
posting bonds--
you know, or the authorities
are aware of who they are.
They have certain responsibilities
and that--
and that they're reputable
citizens is sort of a--
makes a lot of sense in
that particular area.
And it may make sense in this
area in terms of the things.
I mean, you could imagine
a situation
where libraries develop
their own standards for sort
of a self-regulatory-type
proposal where they could sort
of imagine practices that
were reasonable and limited
to the purposes to which
they're authorized to use works
under exceptions and where that
could-- That could flourish.
I think the problem is
you have this lobbying
from the motion picture industry,
the database industry, you know,
a few sectors of the economy, maybe
people with operating software
that were commercial products,
mass market type products
for DRM protection and, you know,
back in 1996 and things like that.
And then, you have these laws that
just sweep everything into it.
And I think that what would have
been better is if sectors that felt
that they deserved to
have the state intervene
and make things illegal would
themselves make the case
that motion pictures deserve
some kind of protection
or it may be other types of works
do as opposed to just starting
with the assumption that
everyone automatically,
no matter what the context
is, basically gets it.
So I think you should
have to make that case
that the state should
have to intervene.
And in terms of the cost of
some of these systems in terms
of managing the cost
of differentiation,
I think it would be reasonable
that the people seeking the state
to provide the legal protection
could pay money to have--
to share some of the cost of
administering these systems,
which are extensive, and that the
people that are seeking to operate
as providing services, they could
also bear some of the cost as well.
I mean, that could be kind
of an approach you might look
in some of the other areas.
The other thing I'd like to call
attention to is that EFF submitted
on April 21st, 2016 in the-- the
Food and Drug Administration,
they submitted comments
on management
of cybersecurity in medical devices.
And they described I think are
quite important some of the growth
of security interests and problems
that you have in medical devices
that are implanted in your body,
which could kill you, that--
you know, where these issues
of DMCA protection come up.
It's just an example of how
far out-- You're going to have,
as other panelists have talked
about, in refrigerators and,
you know, operating your lights,
your-- everything about your home,
it's increasingly becoming-- You
know, we're enveloped in a system
of artificial intelligence,
of people doing everything
you can possibly imagine,
automatically driving
cars, managing your--
I spent $825 yesterday on getting a
pollution control device in my car.
It's probably an aftermarket part.
I have to check.
I think that you've got this--
You've got this sort of bad model
for regulating much more than what
people anticipated 20 years ago.
And I think that you
just have to sort of--
You have to sort of get back
and take a different approach.
You should have to prove
that you get the benefits
of the technical protection from
the government, not just assume
that it's there and then
you have to work backwards.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
I think Mr. Turnbull is next.
>> Bruce Turnbull: I want
to make a couple of points.
One, while we have no
opinion on the sort of things
that are clearly distinct-- I
mean, the auto parts sector--
the concern that we do have is in
drawing the line between functional
and expressive, you could
unintentionally sort
of go too far the other
way, if you will.
And that is that in a DVD
player or a Blu-ray player,
what plays the content
is a computer program.
And so-- And it is subject
to certain requirements
under our licensing agreements
that require that it be robust
against attack in and of itself.
What AACS and DVD CCA
provide are specifications
for how those individual
programs would be developed.
And so, if you-- If you simply
draw the line and say, well,
the content itself, the
expressive work that's encrypted
on the Blu-ray is protected
but the computer program
that plays it is not, that has the
effect of defeating our system.
And we would-- we would be
very concerned about that.
And so, I think in drawing whatever
lines anybody is going to draw,
that I think needs to be
very carefully preserved,
that the functionality that
actually enables the playback
of the expressive content
needs to be protected as well.
The other point I wanted to make
is that something that both DVD CCA
and AACS LA have offered and has
never been taken up on is for people
who are interested
in various exemptions
or various functionalities
that are the subject
of exemption requests periodically
ought to come talk to us about ways
in which this could be done
voluntarily and through tools
that we could cooperatively develop
and could be licensed and agreed
to by the technology providers.
And you know, we've periodically
made efforts to do some on our own.
But we would certainly be
open to cooperative efforts.
>> Regan Smith: Are you suggesting
you could license some sort
of a tool that would allow--
that would otherwise be
implicated by 1201(b)?
>> Bruce Turnbull: Yes.
Well, not-- You would not-- I mean,
it wouldn't be implicated by 1201(b)
because it would be licensed.
So-- but for example, a number
of the exemptions have had to do
with short for-- you know,
clips, short portions of films
that are on DVD or Blu-ray.
There could be a tool that could
be developed that would enable
that specifically and wouldn't
have people using tools that are--
that are copying the entire movie.
And there are various kinds of
ways that that could be done.
And you know, I'm not saying
that it would be easy or simple.
But there are ways that I think
that working together those kinds
of things could be developed.
And then, they could be presented
as part of an exemption if that was,
you know, important aspect of it.
>> Regan Smith: Making it harder for
Mr. Butler to get Handbrake maybe.
>> Bruce Turnbull: Yes, yeah.
Yeah.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
I want to steer the
conversation a little bit back
to Kevin's earlier question,
which was what can we learn
from the Unlocking Act.
And I notice Mr. Perry said
the proposed class 21 was
for an exemption for the auto
industry, auto repair for actions by
or on behalf of an owner.
The Unlocking Act, that language
said that circumvention in the case
of unlocking cell phones may be
initiated by the owner of any
such device or by another person
at the direction of the owner.
So I'm wondering, you know,
we can both think big in terms
of perhaps there's actions
that would require some
sort of statutory reform.
But what are people's opinions
on whether the triennial rulemaking
process should extend to language
such as status or risk,
is there a benefit?
Mr. Adler?
>> Allan Adler: Yeah.
I think we should be very careful--
We need to be very
careful about generalizing
or extrapolating broadly
from what Congress was doing
with respect to that legislation.
And the reason is, is because
the legislation was passed only
after Congress had satisfied
itself that by permitting
such third party assistance,
they were not threatening
anyone's copyrighted works.
Representative of that,
this is a statement
from the House Judiciary
Committee report.
It says, "Circumvention
for unlocking does not compromise
the security of the information
on the phone and it does not expose
any copyrighted works present
on the phone to increased
risk of infringement.
Legalization of circumvention
that has
such harmful effects is not
the intent of this legislation
and it would not be
authorized by its provisions."
The Senate Judiciary Committee
said the same thing in its report.
So--
>> Kevin Amer: Can I just--
>> Allan Adler: -- they
set a pretty high bar
by determining before they acted
that what they were
authorizing was not in fact going
to threaten infringement
of any copyrighted work.
>> Kevin Amer: Can I just ask,
so what sort of evidence would
be useful or relevant to making
that sort of determination?
I mean, would we look to sort
of the prevalence of claims
that are targeting services
rather than devices?
I mean, in sort of evaluating
whether permitting third party
assistance would threaten
a particular market, what--
>> Allan Adler: I mean, over
time, we would be looking
at those kinds of claims.
We would see ultimately whether
or not there would be instances
where allegations of
infringement resulting
from circumvention
could be traced back
to what had been authorized
by the legislation.
I think what Congress did in this
instance and what anybody would have
to do in being a proponent of
such third party assistance is
to actually think through in
fact what is being circumvented
and what are the consequences
of that specific circumvention.
That's what Congress did.
And it was precisely
because it determined
that that authorized circumvention,
done even by third parties,
would not allow them to expose any
copyrighted works to infringement,
was the reason that Congress felt
comfortable authorizing that.
>> Kevin Amer: So would
that be an argument
for allowing the Copyright Office
to make a similar assessment
within the rulemaking or--
>> Allan Adler: No,
quite the contrary.
I think that this is a task that
only Congress should be permitted
to do because it is so
significant in terms
of its potential implications.
And I think it's not something
that can simply be delegated
to either the Register
or the Librarian.
And if I may just add one
other thought in response
to what my friend Brandon
said before, I mean,
we're very sympathetic to the whole
notion about libraries, archives,
academic institutions wanting to
preserve the works that are produced
by the people in my
industry and others.
But there is another avenue
for them to pursue that.
As the Copyright Office well knows,
a few years ago there was a
very comprehensive study done
of section 108 of the Copyright Act
which specifically would have
allowed for addressing questions
about digital preservation,
including preservation of works
that only exist in digital form.
And we have been interested
in seeing that study pursued,
because we're not looking
to essentially leave
these institutions locked
into 20th century technology
capabilities
with respect to preservation.
But there again, you'd be
talking about first the question
of preservation and then
secondly, preservation to what end.
Simply the end of access to
those works ultimately being what
preservation is about, you would
have to be able to determine whether
in fact being able to
circumvent in order
to preserve those works is simply
going to allow access by scholars
and students, faculty,
others who are using them
for legitimate purposes or would
the access policies subsequently
threaten infringement in a way
that might question whether
or not circumvention needed to
be more tightly [inaudible].
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Butler?
>> Brandon Butler: Oh, boy.
Yeah, so I wanted to-- I'll resist
responding to Allan for a minute.
I wanted to come back to something
else briefly, which is another sort
of risk in the question
of whether the beneficiary
of an exemption is going to actually
get the benefit of the exemption.
That's I think a relatively
new risk is the question
of whether the Office will
itself or will ask the proponents
of an exemption to very
narrowly tailor that exemption
so that it steers far clear of
any connection to trafficking,
because I think there are--
there are activities that we would
say are clearly not trafficking.
So, you know, again,
internal assistance, right?
So if an AV librarian is asked by
a faculty member to, you know, to--
how to make a clip-- I'm
entitled to make a clip.
How do I do it?
What do I use?
That's something that we think
is not third party assistance.
It's not trafficking.
It's all internal.
If a documentary filmmaker has
an AV staff person on the staff
of that film, but-- and the wording
of the exemptions in the past--
in the 2010 and in
the 2012 iterations
of the education exception
was nicely crafted I think.
Actually and this is I think
probably on me and my students.
We diverged from that
crafting for reasons
that are lost now to
the mists of time.
But there was a nice crafting that
said sort of the person engaging
in the circumvention would be
allowed to circumvent for purposes
of allowing educational uses
by faculty and students.
So that distinction between the
person and the faculty made plenty
of room in the plain
text for a librarian.
But that got tightened up this
time around and that may be on us.
But I want to make sure that that
is not something that is an outcome
of this concern about
trafficking, where it gets so tight
that you can't have the AV person
on your staff help you work on this.
>> Regan Smith: Mr. Greenstein,
did you want to follow
up on this discussion as to whether,
you know, activities on behalf
of an owner authorized
by should be something
that the Office could consider,
and particularly Mr. Adler's point
that it may be better considered
by Congress but also that Congress,
in doing the Unlocking Act,
was looking at whether
it was implicating access
to copyrighted works?
>> Seth Greenstein: Yes, thank you.
So the legislative history
that Allan was reciting
basically has a principle
that is equally applicable to the
situation that we're talking about.
The reasoning is exactly the same.
Allowing circumvention by an
entity on behalf of the owner
of an automobile does not create any
risk of exercise of anything other
than what's in the exemption.
It does not put at risk the
integrity of access controls
or copy controls over
other types of software.
It is really integral
to the particular exemption
that's being granted.
So similar to the rationale
of, well, we don't--
You know, we want to make sure that
when you unlock the cell phone,
you're not unlocking all of
the apps on the cell phone
or other types of copyrighted works.
It's exactly the same because the
functionality aspect of what was
at issue in the Unlocking Act is the
same kind of functionality concern
at issue with respect
to automobiles.
Similarly, Mr. Adler tried
to draw the distinction
between services and devices.
And at least in the automotive
context, I don't think you can draw
that distinction because
there is no way that Click
and Clack can provide
circumvention service for Toyota,
Volvo, Ford, GM, et cetera.
There is just no way that
they can hire a hacking expert
who understands the ins and
outs and intricacies of all
of that different software.
For some models, up to 70
or more software modules
in a particular automobile
and different for each
and every model of automobile.
There is no way that they
can do that themselves.
They need to rely on others
who can create the tools
that make that possible.
>> Regan Smith: So you're saying
there needs to be a market
for software for circumvention in
the aftermarket or auto repair?
>> Seth Greenstein: Yes, and
I'm intrigued by the suggestion
that there might be
some kind of, you know,
authorization for locksmiths
or something along those lines.
I'm not sure that I agree with it.
But I'm at least intrigued
by the direction of that.
>> Kevin Amer: Well, which
way does that cut though?
I mean, if we're, you know--
If you can't separate services
from devices, is there a concern
that allowing services could
incentivize the growth of a market,
you know-- incentivize
the development of tools
which I think some would be
concerned couldn't be limited
in their use to things
covered by an exemption?
>> Seth Greenstein: I don't
think that concern exists
for the particular market
that we're concerned with,
the automotive market, because
the nature of the software is
so particularized and particularized
to each and every model of car,
that I don't think you
have a generalized concern
of a one-size-breaks-all.
You know, this is really a
situation where a specific tool has
to be provided for a specific piece
of software, for a particular part
and function of a particular
model of automobile.
>> Regan Smith: So I want
to ask one more follow-up
about the auto industry
and open it up and then get
to Mr. Kupferschmid,
who has been patient.
But you know, during the rulemaking,
we heard a lot about the memorandums
of understanding and sort
of voluntary initiatives
and partnerships.
And Mr. Turnbull just suggested in
audiovisual that, you know, his--
who he represents is open
to voluntary initiatives.
Is there some way to facilitate
cooperation with the aftermarket,
that short of, you
know, upending 1201(b)?
>> Seth Greenstein: I have very
strong doubts that that is possible,
which is why even despite
the existence--
Look, if the memorandum of
understanding had solved this issue,
Auto Care Association would not be
here on behalf of its 3000 members.
It does not address
all of the issues.
And the circumvention aspects, well,
the anti-circumvention tools are
becoming more and more intricate
and particularized
each and every day
and often have absolutely nothing
to do with the copyrighted work.
For example, this particular
software that's put
in automobiles can be tied
to the vehicle identification
number of that vehicle.
And that's purely for
anticompetitive purposes.
It has nothing to do with the
copyrighted work or the expression
or even the functionality.
It's purely to protect the market.
But yet, there's no way to provide
circumvention for that aspect
of the car or the software alone
without addressing the other
aspects of circumvention.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Perry, did you want to
chime in on that question?
>> David Perry: Right.
Well, if, I mean, if you're
playing devil's advocate,
I don't think our client or Mr.
Greenstein's constituents want sort
of wild abandonment in the world
of the aftermarket for automobiles.
Nobody wants a safety, you know,
a safety hazard and trafficking
of any kind of software
or anti-circumvention
device that's going
to make it unsafe for any of us.
But to-- You know, if
there's a suggestion--
if you're on the side of the
automobile manufacturers,
if there's a suggestion
that, well, it's already--
it's available, you just have to
come to us and we'll license it
to you, I think that
suggestion is kind of deceptive.
It's not practical.
You know, the after-- I think
the benefits of allowing,
at least in this industry, the
aftermarket to do what they have
to do far outweigh the
parade of horribles
that could be attributed to it.
And you know, I think I agree with
what Mr. Greenstein is saying about,
you know, VIN-specific software
means a very real issue.
I mean, if you are in
the bay, in your garage,
and you find that the software, you
know, for one Ford F-150 or GM is,
you know, for this car and
then there is a different one
for that car, it makes it-- from
a practical standpoint, copyright
and DRM has now impacted your
ability to do what 25 years ago used
to be done on a regular basis.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Kupferschmid?
>> Keith Kupferschmid: Thank you.
I hope you'll give me
a little bit of leeway.
A lot of questions have passed
since I put my card up here.
>> Regan Smith: Yeah, you can
take it back a little bit.
>> Keith Kupferschmid: Trying
to keep this all on track.
So I think kind of going in
reverse order here, I have to admit,
I don't know that much
about the auto industry.
And I do know there's this
sort of MOU we've been talking
about and voluntary agreement.
I don't know how that came about.
I hear from you all that
it doesn't do the job.
But frankly, that's-- excuse me--
one of the beauties of voluntary
agreements is you can hopefully go
back to the parties that
you were able to bring
to the table the first time and
say, hey, this isn't working.
Can we come up with some mutually
agreeable solutions and update it?
I mean, that's a lot
easier to do than sort
of running to Congress, I think.
Our concern, as I think
Kevin mentioned a while ago,
is of course once you've got these
anti-trafficking tools are available
in the marketplace, even if they're
for ostensibly lawful purposes,
they will inevitably become useful
for-- or used for unlawful purposes
and make them impossible to police.
Now, we've heard, that at least
in the auto industry, no, no, no,
that's sort of very specific.
But then we've also heard, wait
a minute, you can't divide--
do this dividing line
between devices and services.
They want the dividing line between
functional and expressive, OK?
And that becomes a
concern because, you know,
where do you draw that line, right?
Is Adobe Photoshop
functional or expressive?
What about TurboTax?
What about iWatch, or the
software on your iWatch?
I mean, at the heart of it,
all software is functional,
at least to a degree, or at
least I would hope it would be.
And so, sort of drawing that
line, I think it's interesting
and telling that, you
know, I participated
in the embedded software
roundtable on Wednesday.
And we kind of separated
these two issues.
But it's clear they should not have
been separated because it was sort
of taboo to talk about 1201
on Wednesday and now it's--
We're talking probably more
about embedded software today
than we are specifically 1201 or
the anti-trafficking provisions.
Ultimately, I think we have
to be really, really careful
about where we draw the
lines, how we draw the lines.
I made this point on Wednesday.
It could lead to a lot of
inadvertent consequences.
And in this particular instance,
you know, things seem to be,
like I said, working quite well.
I know that's not true
across the board.
But we have to be careful
not to throw the baby
out with the bathwater here.
I think in terms of the auto
industry, maybe other industries,
voluntary agreements and working
sort of outside of Congress is,
sort of, probably a better approach,
a better way to go about trying
to solve this problem
that we're hearing today.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Sheffner, and I think, again,
if you feel like we're talking
about 1201 and if that implicates
embedded software, feel free.
We heard about the swear
jar from Wednesday.
But you can answer the question if
it specifically implicates 1201.
>> Ben Sheffner: All right.
I'll try to be brief because Mr.
Kupferschmid actually just made
several of the points
that I intended to.
But I'd go back, I think,
two or three questions ago
about whether the Copyright
Office itself is authorized
under the statute to create
exceptions to the prohibitions
on trafficking
and anti-circumvention
devices and services.
And as June Besek said
a few minutes ago,
I think the answer is clearly no.
And I believe that the Copyright
Office itself has acknowledged
that in previous rulemakings.
And I actually don't even think
anybody here today has suggested
that the Copyright Office on its
own, under the current statute,
can create those exemptions.
>> Regan Smith: And so, to be
clear, you're taking the language
of the Unlocking Act, for example,
you think would necessarily--
requires Congress?
>> Ben Sheffner: Yeah.
I mean, I think that's further-- I
think it was done that way in part
because of an acknowledgement
that the current statute does
not permit the Copyright Office
to do that on its own.
And again, I don't believe
anybody here has argued
that the Copyright Office
can create exemptions
to the prohibitions on trafficking.
>> Regan Smith: And do
you agree with Mr. Adler
that the Copyright Office--
there should not be a reform
so that the Copyright Office could
make the determination whether
service on behalf of an owner
might implicate copyrighted works?
I mean, and I'm thinking, you
know, perhaps providing a way,
whether there could be
an evidentiary basis
so the Office could, for example,
draw a line between circumventions
for motion pictures
versus auto repair.
>> Ben Sheffner: We would
agree with Mr. Adler
that the time is not right
to open up the statute.
I mean, I think, look, there are
legitimate policy arguments here,
you know, especially by
the auto repair people.
I mean, I would point out-- We
haven't heard from the other side
on that issue, at least
at this forum.
So I don't think you
should necessarily take
as gospel everything you've heard
on that without hearing-- Yeah.
>> Regan Smith: No, I mean--
And obviously we're also
looking at written comments.
>> Ben Sheffner: Absolutely.
But yes, as Mr. Adler said,
this is a major policy change
that I think I would
require an act of Congress.
Then of course, once you open
up the act, we're not just going
to be talking about
this one specific issue.
I mean there's-- lots of people
have lots of different concerns,
things they would like to change,
not just about section 1201,
but of course other
aspects of the DMCA thing.
It's impossible to
confine it to that.
And then, just to quickly
wrap up, I think you asked one
or two questions ago about,
well, what are the risks
if we do permit exemptions for the--
exemptions to the anti-trafficking
provisions.
I think we've touched
on some of them before.
But again, look, the basic problem
is that even if you acknowledge
that there might be legitimate
reasons or that there are people
who have been granted exemptions
to engage in circumvention
and need a device or a
service or a piece of software
to do what they want to do,
the problem is that those--
especially as to devices
or pieces of software,
obviously can't differentiate
between the legitimate
and the illegitimate uses, at
least as to motion pictures.
I mean, once you put it on
the shelf at Walmart, yes,
you might have people-- you
know, Mr. Butler may be able and,
you know, his colleagues would
use it for legitimate purposes
under the, you know,
under the exemptions
that they've been granted.
But probably the vast majority
of consumers would think, hey,
here's a piece of software.
It says that I can rip
DVDs and Blu-ray players.
That sounds kind of nifty.
I should be able to do that.
And it actually sort of-- It
confuses consumers and misleads them
into thinking that it's a
legitimate activity where it's not.
>> Kevin Amer: I just wonder though,
you know, where does that leave us
and is there any sort of
proposal that you would suggest?
I mean, just sort of anecdotally
at least, it would seem plausible
to conclude that there, you
know, is a material set of people
who are beneficiaries of exemptions
who, just as a practical matter,
don't have the technical
capability to circumvent.
So I just wonder are we stuck just
without any sort of
possible solution?
I mean, I think one thing that we've
suggested is, well, what, you know--
could we be granted
authority to at least consider
that as part of the rulemaking?
>> Ben Sheffner: Well, I would
say at least as to motion pictures
and the exemptions that have been
granted as to audiovisual works,
I actually don't think
there's a problem.
I mean, I think Mr. Butler
acknowledged them, you know,
a few minutes ago, and I
wrote down what he said.
He said, with quote, "We haven't
been terribly deterred from engaging
in the activity which is
authorized by the exemptions that he
and his colleagues
have been granted."
>> Kevin Amer: Yeah,
but-- And is he talking
about prohibited activity or--
>> Ben Sheffner: Well, I'm not
saying that he's been engaged.
>> Kevin Amer: Well, right.
>> Ben Sheffner: Or
that-- And I don't think--
and frankly, by going--
by going off--
>> Kevin Amer: But I mean, I
think that's the argument, right?
I mean, that you're
just sort of, you know,
encouraging people to break the law.
>> Ben Sheffner: Well,
I don't believe
that I've accused Mr.
Butler of breaking the law.
What I've acknowledged is the
practical reality that he is able
to go and find tools to do
what he's been authorized to do
by the Copyright Office
and that the other--
the other option, which
is to say, OK,
well he's been granted
the exemption,
therefore there should be, you
know, a lawful market in trafficking
and anti-circumvention
devices, has worse results,
has worse consequences,
that look at--
that I will say that the
situation today isn't perfect.
But the alternative of permitting,
you know, a legitimate market
in circumvention devices or
software would be much worse.
And it would just mainstream
that activity
and in a sense swallow the rule
against circumvention itself.
>> Kevin Amer: OK.
Thank you.
Mr. Schwartz?
>> Robert S. Schwartz: Well,
just as a rhetorical question,
I know you're here to ask
questions, but if everybody agrees
that the Copyright Office
and Register Librarian do not
have the power to grant exemptions
with respect to trafficking,
then why worry about giving
that appearance in the course of
legitimately acting on a petition
for exemption that is before you?
To get to this point, as you did in
the case of autos, you already need
to conclude that this
is a lawful activity
that is being petitioned for.
So why is it necessary,
again rhetorically--
is it necessary to look down the
page to (a)(2) and (b)(1) and say,
oh my gosh, if we grant
this petition in the terms
for which it's been petitioned for,
so as to-- however you phrase it--
allow some expert assistance in
the form of a service or, you know,
somebody's aftermarket product or
software, no court is going to say--
because they can read the law too--
that, oh my gosh, we're not going
to allow this case against a
trafficker to proceed under the DMCA
because the Copyright
Office granted an exemption
to a user who had a lawful right.
I mean, respectfully, I don't agree
that the law should be interpreted
to take that power away
from the Copyright Office.
The NTIA didn't think so
in its recommendations.
At least our reading of
the legislative history,
when you read all of the
legislative history at the time
that this was presented to the
Congress in terms of black boxes
and for one purpose and not wanting
to interfere with interoperability
or the legitimate activities
of retailers and servicers.
So again, back to your question
of what evidence is necessary,
once you've concluded that
the activity is lawful
and you've concluded that
it doesn't involve copying
of expressive content, if you still
need to look for any evidence,
if you're worried about
trafficking, then look to those
who oppose the exemption
to provide such evidence.
Otherwise, there should be a
presumption under the power
that you already have that it
includes the right to expert help,
just as it was silently
assumed in the case of phones,
or else nobody would have
ever gotten the benefit
of those exemptions.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
>> Andrew Moore: So turning--
Sorry, turning away a little bit
from the rulemaking process,
the Unlocking Technology Act is
proposing to amend 1201 (a)(2)
to tie trafficking to-- rather
than to circumvention specifically,
but to facilitating
infringement by circumvention.
I was wondering if I could get your
thoughts on that as an alternative.
>> Kevin Amer: Just-- I know
there were a couple of cards up.
If you all wanted to respond
to previous questions,
I think feel free to do so, while
others can think about a response
to the proposed legislation.
So, Mr. Butler?
>> Brandon Butler: Sure.
So just to sort of revise and extend
my remarks from a minute ago, the--
while Handbrake seems to work fairly
well, a problem that we've seen--
and a general problem that we've
seen in all of these panels
from beneficiaries is we
don't know what we don't know
about how much better these things
could be, how harmed we are,
what we can and can't do because
our behaviors are shaped by the law.
So we have Handbrake.
Handbrake does what Handbrake does.
That seems to be great.
We don't know what someone would do
if Mr. Turnbull were to license them
and they were to take full
advantage or if they were
to get the benefit of an exemption.
We don't know what the
market would do in terms
of generating better tools.
We also-- We just got an exemption
for Blu-ray, and Blu-ray is harder.
And I'm actually looking forward
in a perverse way, looking for a,
you know, I'm curious
what will happen.
Will people really get to use it?
Because it is harder.
It takes longer.
It's a big file.
There are sort of two or three
different software processes
involved in the ripping.
So how will that work
as easily as DVD.
And then, of course, in the
future what's going to happen?
And none of this stuff is going
to be on the shelf at Walmart.
And so, if that's what we're
worried about, let's, you know,
open the floodgates for
the specialized users
because they're not-- You know,
mechanics don't shop at Walmart
for the products that
they need to rip cars.
We don't shop at Walmart for
the products that we need.
You know, the digital
preservation librarian
at UVA has this huge bizarre
computer tower thing that has all
of these obsolete drives in it.
It's a specialized tool.
That's the kind of stuff that
we buy and we shop from people
who sell that kind of stuff.
And it's not Walmart.
So that might be helpful.
Maybe there's some consensus here.
If we can keep it out of
Walmart, it's all good.
>> Regan Smith: Ms. Besek?
>> June Besek: I just want
to make a couple of points.
One is on the power of
the Copyright Office
to allow circumvention
services or tools.
You know, I heard the quote
from legislative history.
But first of all, that was
a statement on the floor.
So I think we have to take
that as that individual's view.
And secondly, legislative
history one only resorts
to if the statute isn't clear.
And I think in this case,
the statute is fairly clear.
So that's obviously the
first place you go to,
to understand the statute.
The other point I want to
make is about the functional
versus expressive approach.
I've been in copyright
now for 30 years
and I really never thought
I'd spend as much time talking
about automobile repair
as we have today.
And I find it a little
disconcerting.
And I am-- I really would not want
decisions about automobile repair
and replacement parts to
drive-- no pun intended--
the decisions about circumvention,
circumvention devices,
circumvention services.
And if that means ultimately
there has to be some distinction
between software that governs
functional works and then,
on the other hand, expressive works.
And on that expressive works side, I
would add anything that has to deal
with any kind of playback device.
Then maybe that's the
route we have to go on.
But if-- you know, I'm concerned
that, you know, there is a lot
of understandable concern
on the part of the public
about not being able
to get replacement parts
for functional devices.
And if that is going to affect
the rules that govern, you know,
books on e-book readers and movies
and all those kinds of things,
then I think that we have to
jettison some of those things
or treat them separately.
Because I don't think
that ultimately
that copyright interests are
going to win the hearts and minds
of the American people on this.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
So we have a couple of placards up.
If you care to respond
to the question
about the Unlocking Act,
we would welcome that.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Yes, the proposed Unlocking--
>> Regan Smith: The
Unlocking Technology Act.
>> Kevin Amer: -- Technology
Act that's been proposed.
Mr. Love, did you have--
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Andrew Moore: Yeah, sorry.
The Unlocking Technology Act that
was proposed ties circumvention
in 1201 (a)(2) to facilitating
infringement by circumvention.
So I was wondering what
your opinions were on that.
>> James Love: I would agree with
Professor Besek's comment about,
you know, not worried about the--
about, you know, like the
automobile industry sort
of driving the copyright thing.
You could also turn that on its head
and you could sort of say, you know,
the rest of the economy maybe
doesn't want the motion picture
industry and, you know,
the book industry
to drive the rest of
the economy either.
I think that the marriage
between these two things is--
I would agree it is problematic.
I go back to the idea on the act.
I think it'd be good if you imagine
at least two tiers of approaches,
one for areas where you think maybe
the whole regime is kind of intended
for in the first instance and
where people feel comfortable
that they're kind of working
towards solutions in that area.
And then, a second area where kind
of the collateral damage of the DMC,
you know, where automobile
sector, medical devices,
garage door openers, inkjet
cartridges, all that sort of stuff.
And then-- and that you
begin again the process
of not treating everything
exactly the same.
In Europe-- By the way, in that
licensing issue that was brought
up before-- in Europe,
there's an obligation in the--
for copyright owners
to take measures
that make exceptions
available to people.
It isn't really clear what happens
if they don't take those measures.
But it's sort of-- You know, there
is an affirmative obligation.
I don't think there's any obligation
like that in the US system
and I think that's a mistake.
If you really want the automobile
manufacturers to license people
to compete against them
and sell cheaper parts
than the automobile manufacturer
wants to charge themselves
and they have no obligation
to do so,
I don't see why they
would want to do that.
And so, this idea that people
within a sector should have
to have an affirmative obligation to
license the technology or the tools
or whatever like that to address
something is a first step,
but also puts an obligation on
people that are seeking to traffic
in devices and things
like that to pursue
that opportunity before they resort
to their own do-it-yourself
kind of remedies as well.
That may be kind of a
compromise where you have a step
where the people that are
affected the most by it have--
you know, have to be approached,
work out the basic details,
understand kind of what the
parameters and the debate are.
And then if that fails, you know,
then you can sort of imagine kind
of things moving on to like a
different set of obligations.
I just want to mention
also in the licensing
that in President Obama's
books on Kindle,
text-to-speech is turned
off on almost all of them.
And this is after like
massive protest in front
of the Authors Guild and tons
of letters to the president
of the United States from blind
people, a fairly high profile thing.
And if you go on Amazon
right now and check
on President Obama's Kindle things,
you will see that text-to-speech
is turned off.
So this is essentially
a licensing scenario,
it's a technical protection measure.
This is either a switch
that's either turned
on or turned off by Amazon.
Random House famously turns
it off as a default position.
And it just goes to the frustration
people have when say just call us up
and we'll fix the problem.
That doesn't really often work.
And I think people have to recognize
that that's not a very
satisfying thing for consumers,
just sort of say that
the people will fix it,
particularly when you have
devices where things have moved on,
there's a lot of cost
in fixing the problem.
Interoperability interfaces
have changed.
People talk about having
refrigerators with blue screens
of death because the
software no longer works.
I think you have to recognize that
people just don't follow through
and fix a lot of these problems.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
So we have just a couple
of minutes left.
So I think this is going to
be the last call for comments,
and if we can try to
keep them brief.
But I think since your comments,
Mr. Love, involved Random House
and publishing, we'll
call on Mr. Adler next.
Thank you.
>> Allan Adler: I just wanted to
address the previous question,
if I could quickly respond
to Jamie, on the issue--
>> Regan Smith: I think-- speak a
little closer on the microphone?
>> Allan Adler: Yeah.
On the issue of an
infringement nexus with access,
we already discussed that in
the first panel yesterday.
So I won't repeat the
comments I've made,
just simply refer you back to them.
But I would also point out that
with respect to (a)(2) and (b),
what Congress did was 14 years
before Congress enacted this
statute, Sony decision
by the Supreme Court had
addressed the question of whether
or not articles in
commerce that could be used
to infringe could be prohibited.
And the Court articulated a standard
that talked about not wanting
to see prohibition
affecting articles that were--
could be used to infringe
but were capable
of substantial non-infringing uses.
And most people spent the next
14 years and probably the time
since then figuring out
exactly what that meant.
So what Congress did here in the
anti-trafficking provisions was
to try to be more specific
about what the criteria were.
And it's unquestioned
that that criteria is
in fact linked to infringing works.
So I don't think there's any
need for new legislation on that.
And just quickly with respect to
Jamie's comments about whether
or not text-to-screen
translation software
or the read-aloud functionality
in e-books is turned off,
that turns out to be more a matter
of individual competitive
preference among publishers
and typically is a function
of the way publishers negotiate
agreements with authors.
Usually it's if there
is an audiobook
that is also being authorized
for publication by the author,
they do not want the e-book to
have the read-aloud functionality
because they tend to think it
competes with the audiobook.
But again, that tends to be
more of a contractual issue
between the author
and the publisher.
It is not something that is
done-- just as a matter of course
or particularly because of concern
about violations specifically
of a copyright right.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Kupferschmid?
>> Keith Kupferschmid: Yeah.
I just-- I'll be very, very brief.
I just wanted to address
comments that Mr. Love made,
not only just recently,
but throughout that sort
of this law is being
driven or is especially
for the motion picture studios
or the book publishing industry
or the record labels
or anybody like that.
I can tell you that, you know, we
represent over 15,000, you know,
sort of small businesses and
individual creators in this space.
And they're very much supportive
of the anti-trafficking provisions.
Specifically, do they sue
or do they enforce the law?
No, they don't have
the capability of that.
They don't even oftentimes
don't have the capability
to actually bring infringement
cases either.
And matter of fact, that's exactly
why they like this provision
in the law because
otherwise they would be
in this arms race just
like everyone else.
And that's an arms race that the
individual creator is absolutely
going to lose.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Turnbull?
>> Bruce Turnbull: Just
very quickly, first,
I wanted to associate myself
with what Mr. Adler said
about the Unlocking Technology Act.
I won't repeat it.
But I agree with that.
Secondly, with regard to the
language, going back a while
in the discussion, that was in the
prior librarian-related exemptions,
the DVD CCA had agreed and accepted
that language and would again
and think that that
would be within the scope
of the Copyright Office's
authority and would be appropriate
in those kinds of exemptions.
And similarly, the
Copyright Office has in--
or the Librarian, in the
exemptions that have been granted,
conditioned certain of
the exemptions on the use
of certain kinds of
screen capture software.
Either as a prerequisite to
circumventing or in a couple
of cases specifically as the method
for allowing circumvention and so,
I think there's precedent for
that kind of thing at least
in very specific cases where there's
been an adequate record developed
and that sort of thing.
And in terms of the
sort of voluntary tool
that I was talking about, it
would be in that kind of vein
that we would envision
it being used,
as something that would be brought
to the Copyright Office
cooperatively
but would then be part
of an exemption.
>> Regan Smith: OK, thank you.
So Mr. Greenstein, next,
you know, last call,
and I was in the next panel
is about permanent exemptions.
And I thought maybe I could also
invite you to comment on whether
in your particular situation for the
auto industry, that might be sort
of another work around
rather if changing 1201(b).
>> Seth Greenstein: OK.
Thank you.
So first, with respect to
the Unlocking Technology Act,
it probably would solve the
problems of our industry.
But I think it's a much broader
solution than is necessary.
And in that respect, I note
Professor Besek, you know,
talked about how, you know, this
is really kind of a separate issue.
Well, that's why we
sought an exemption,
because it really is something
that is an individual need
and I think best addressed
in that way.
And from that perspective,
I think, you know,
permanent exemptions
are a positive solution.
But merely adopting
the current solution
as a permanent exemption is
not going to solve the problems
of the aftermarket
automobile repair industry.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
And Mr. Schwartz, I think
you have the last word.
>> Robert S. Schwartz:
Yeah, just finally,
I didn't mean to not comment on
the Unlocking Technology Act.
I believe CTA has supported that.
Of course, you know, as in the case
with any legislative consideration,
we'd want to look at what's
being proposed, you know,
exactly now in the most up-to-date
formulation after discussion.
But I think CTA is in support of it.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Well, that will conclude this panel.
We are supposed to start at 10:45.
So that cuts the break
short by about 10 minutes.
I think we should be on track
to just start that on time.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.